prend du mieux elle va célébrer les
fêtes 2022 avec son tout nouveau rang
offert par un pur inconnu son donneur a
répondu à un appel à tous sur les
réseaux sociaux il y a un an j'ai publié
sur Facebook un poste qui disait j'ai
besoin d'aide j'ai 36 ans 35 ans à
l'époque je veux des enfants puis j'ai
besoin d'un rein pour pouvoir créer ma
famille et puis aller mieux puis aller
retravailler puis finalement j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un grâce à ça heureusement pour
elle parce qu'elle était sur une liste
d'attentes pour un don cadavérique qui
l'aurait obligé à patienter encore
plusieurs années avant d'être greffé et
l'avantage du don vivant et inestimable
avec les greffes de donneurs vivants
comme on a des excellents donneurs et
que le temps passé sur la glace du
greffon et minimale souvent
le rein se met probablement à produire
de l'urine dès la salle d'opération le
chirurgien le voit le rein se met à
produire de l'urine il se met à filtrer
le sang très rapidement au niveau
médical il fonctionne ma créatinine tu
as 83 dans la normale ce serait en 50 et
100 que mon rêve fonctionne presque
autant que si j'avais deux reins normaux
qui fonctionnent bien fait que il
extraordinaire en fait je pouvais pas
m'attendre à un meilleur rein j'ai dit
de maintenant convaincre d'abord de
l'importance de signer sa carte et
d'aviser ses proches de leur intention
de donner leurs organes en cas de décès
mais aussi de réfléchir au fait de
donner un rein de son vivant qu'on a un
don vivant non seulement on se retire de
la liste mais on permet à quelqu'un
d'autre d'avoir la chance
le don vivant c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait pas souvent au Québec mais qui est
fait ailleurs dans le monde et qui
gagnerait à être fait parce que tout le
monde devrait avoir le droit de venir de
retrouver sa vie finalement puis ça se
fait puis c'est sécuritaire pour le
donneur et pour le receveur ton donneur
se porte bien il a été touché par
l'histoire de Judith et son désir de
fonder une famille
ici je les grands noms Radio-Canada
Trois-Rivières